I have hemorrhoids for years and they would bleed at times however I now bleed with almost every
bowel movement that dealt with severe constipation during chemo. Is it safe to continue doing coffee
elements? Well, it's yes and no. So if you're bleeding from the hemorrhoids and you're inserting
the tube in your rectum and it's irritating the hemorrhoids that I'd say no. But if you're saying,
well now it's not, the tube is not irritating and that's not the issue that I'd say go ahead,
you'll have to kind of discern that for yourself. But if inserting the tube is what is majorly
causing irritation to the hemorrhoids, that's just going to cause further inflammation and make
those worse. So no, definitely you want to look at a constipation. Know how she'd also look at that
detoxification course here because the detoxification course memory of free access is your
username and password that you use to get into the membership site. The detoxification course lays out
the seven phases of detoxification and it's phase six of detoxification that you want to be aware of
phase six has to do with elimination. So in that course, I lay out things that you want to take to
help with elimination to soften your stool so you're not buried down when you're going to the
bathroom or not having any constipation issues and you're keeping very loose stools. So your main
things for that would be what are called phase six assist which is our private label, a product that
has an allo in it called cape allo that will really help with constipation probably more than anything
else that you've ever taken. Several other different products depending on what kind of issues
you're having and how bad your constipation is. So look at seven phases of detoxification course
and I think that will be a good help for you right there. So by that on our website,
stop our website and you'll see courses.